haben 27 juni wurden 150 soldaten der
garnison in vor dem schloss belvedere
feierlich angelobt
die angelobung von im beisein des
bundesministers magister klug und seines
serbischen amtskollegen bronislaw gazit
statt der zu einem arbeitsgespräch nach
wien gekommen war
bundesminister klug erinnerte an die
einsätze des bundesheeres wo die
soldaten im in und ausland schutz und
hilfe gewährleistet
abschließend wünschte er den jungen
soldaten einen spannenden und
unfallfreien wehrdienst und dass die
bevölkerung stolz auf die leistungen der
soldaten sein kann
die feierliche angelobung findet ihren
höhepunkt wenn die rekruten den eid auf
die republik österreich ablegen